it has been a stunning reversal
Ukrainian troops have swept into
kharkave region sending Russian troops
who've controlled the area fleeing in
Village after Village Ukrainian Fighters
have moved in welcomed by local
residents
Ukrainian flags raised once more across
the region
this man says the Russians were here
then started shouting and running away
charging off in their tanks the mayor of
their Hachi tore up the Russian flag
amid cheers
the Ukrainian military posted pictures
of abandoned Russian tanks and equipment
it is not the first major Retreat last
winter Russia controlled Crimea and
Donetsk the start of the war saw a
military Onslaught from multiple
directions eventually Russians pulled
back to maintain a hold on much of
eastern Ukraine but in recent days a
Ukrainian counter-offensive around
kharkiv has taken back about 3 000
square kilometers of territory according
to Ukraine
president zielinski addressed the
Ukrainian forces saying the world is
impressed the enemy is panicking
the gains are believed to be crucial for
Ukraine to maintain political support
and Military supplies from its allies
it's probably the most significant
battle and moment of this war Ukraine
needed to demonstrate to its Western
backers the United States many European
nations Canada included that it does
have a chance to win this war in Moscow
the Russian retreat was called a
grouping operation
but even on Russian television signs of
discontent with how the war is going
this former member of the state Duma
declaring that Vladimir Putin was badly
advised about what could be achieved and
it could mean that the knives are coming
out for for Vladimir Putin right now the
fear is that Putin will respond with
greater brutality
Russian airstrikes destroyed a power
plant on the weekend plunging much of
kharkiv Into Darkness but for now across
Ukraine Spirits have been lifted
after months of enduring Russian
destruction in the recaptured community
of hoptifka troops declare the task is
complete
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto